فاتوره التغييرات المناخيه تكلف البشره
الشيء الكثير سواء في الارواح او
الممتلكات فالارقام المسجله على امتداد 50
عاما تثير القلق حول التاثير الكبير
للتغيرات المناخيه بهذا الخصوص اظهر تقرير
لمنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه انماط
الطقس القاسيه تسببت بوفاه اكثر من مليوني
شخص في العالم وبخسائر تقدر بنحو 4.3
تريليون دولار فذلك خلال مده 50 عاما
وكالعاده كانت البلدان الناميه الاكثر
تضررا من الكوارث الطبيعيه المنظمه
العالميه للارصاد الجويه دائما اكتشفت ان
البلدان الناميه
من الوفيات و60% من الخسائر الاقتصاديه
الناجمه عن الكوارث الطبيعيه وشهدت اسيا
اعلى حصيله للوفيات بسبب الظروف المناخيه
القاسيه على مدار الخمسين عاما الماضيه مع
ما يقرب من مليون حاله وفاه اما في
افريقيا فان حالات الجفاف تسببت في حوالي
95% من عدد الوفيات الناجمه عن الكوارث
المناخذه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات